chicago but let's begin with senior
correspondent claudia cowan she's live
in san francisco for us tell us what's
going on there the city is suing the
school district
well that's right dana the city has
simply run out of patience here
saying that the school district and the
board of education have failed to lay
out a comprehensive plan to get kids
back into classrooms
just as soon as possible that is a
violation of a state mandate hence
we now have this lawsuit it's been
nearly 11 months
since students here in san francisco and
indeed across
the country started learning remotely
but while many
other districts and even san francisco's
private schools have gone back to class
public schools remain closed even though
the city's own health department
says they could reopen safely with
proper precautions
the lawsuit aims to force district
officials to develop a plan
and a timeline unfortunately
the plan prepared by the san francisco
unified school district and adopted by
the board of education
is ambiguous empty rhetoric it is a plan
to make a plan and is legally
insufficient
the city's mayor agrees and says the
district's 54 thousand students are
suffering academically and emotionally
and that the school board's priorities
are off
last week for instance it announced it
would rename schools that some consider
offensive including abraham lincoln and
george washington
the school board has alienated parents
and made national news for their focus
on renaming
44 of our schools all while there wasn't
a plan to reopen those very same schools
the district superintendent says there
is a plan to reopen in place
while the school board maintains its top
priority is the health of both
students and staff
we understand that this is painful and
we all want to get back but this is an
embarrassing day for san francisco
while not named specifically in this
lawsuit much of what happens next
depends
on how things go with the labor unions
and what kind of working conditions
teachers are willing to accept
previously they said they wanted to wait
until san francisco had moved back into
the less restrictive
orange tier dana that is two tiers away
from where we are now
vaccinations for the entire school staff
also
part of these ongoing negotiations maybe
they can use the cdc's own
scientist saying that it's good to go
and when they sue
in court claudia cowan thank you from